[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا حلقه جديده من مستقبل
الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
استيراد اوروبا للغاز المسال قفز ستين في
المئه العمل الماضي فمن اين اتت به
[موسيقى]
والرئيس التنفيذي لاكوا باور يقول ان
الشركه ستضاعف محفظه اصولها باكثر من ثلاث
مرات خلال ثمان سنوات
[موسيقى]
بعد اشهر صعبه عاشتها اوروبا منذ مطلع فصل
الخريف الماضي يبدو انه هو مع اقتراب
الربيع بدات الامور تزهر شيئا فشيئا
بالنسبه للقاره العجوز فها هي اسعار
الجمله للغاز الطبيعي هناك تنخفض الى ادنى
مستوياتها في 18 شهرا
وذلك على خلفيه شتاء اكثر دفئا من المعتاد
ومخزونات شبه ممتلئه من الغاز اضف الى ذلك
الجهود الاوروبيه لتنويع مصادر وارداتها
من الغاز ليبدو ان اوروبا اجتازت امتحان
اول شتاء لها من دون الغاز الروسي بسلام
وباتت فرصها لاجتياز الشتاء القادم افضل
واذا ما احتاج احدهم لمزيد من التطمينات
ها هي محطه تسيير الغاز الامريكيه
تعود للعمل بعد توقف بدا في يونيو من
العام الماضي علما ان هذه المحطه كانت
توفر قبل توقفها نحو 10% من اجمالي واردات
الغاز المسال الاوروبيه
بكل المقاييس عام 20 22 كان علامه فارقه
في سوق الغاز المسال العالميه حيث انه وفي
ضوء الاحداث الجيو السياسيه واثارها شهدت
السوق تغيرات هيكليه ابرزها طبعا بروز
الطلب الاوروبي بقوه للتعويض عن واردات
الغاز الروسي عبر الانابيب هذه التغيرات
ظهرت بشكل جلي في التقرير السنوي عن الغاز
المسائل الصادر قبل ايام عن شركه شيل اكبر
متداول في الغاز المسال في العالم فقد نمى
سوق الغاز المساء العالميا عام 2022
الى
396 مليون طن بنسبه نمو سنويه بلغت 4%
اوروبا كانت بطبيعه الحال اكبر مستورد
بحجم بلغه 121 مليون طن نمو سنوي فاقه
الستين في المئه
في اوروبا نفسها اكبر نمو سنوي في
الواردات جاء من فرنسا بحجم 12 مليون طن
تالتها بريطانيا بزياده بلغت ثمانيه
ملايين طن بدا واضحا من الارقام مشاهدينا
ان الزياده في واردات اوروبا لم يكن
بمقدور السوق تلبيتها من دون انخفاض
متزامن في الواردات الذي شهدته في نفس
الفتره كلا من الصين بواقع 15 مليون طن
والبرازيل بواقع خمسه ملايين طن واخيرا
الهند بحوالي اربعه ملايين طن ومن خلال
ارقام عام 2022 يمكننا التوصل لعده
استنتاجات اولها بان نمو الطلب الاوروبي
لن يكون غير متكرر بمعنى لن يكون عابرا بل
هو باقن خصوصا مع تزايد عدد وحدات اعاده
التغويز والتخزين العائمه التي يتم
تدشينها في المانيا وفي ايطاليا هذا العام
جميعها عوامل تدلل على تزايد الطلب ثاني
الاستنتاجات هو ان اوروبا والصين
سيتنافسان حتما على امدادات الغاز المسال
المحدوده ولكن القوه ستميل لكافه الصين
فتاريخيا اوروبا كانت هي السوق الموازنه
حيث لم يكن لديها نمو قوي في الطلب وكانت
معتمده بشكل رئيسي على غاز الانابيب
الروسي منخفض الكلفه وهذا ما سمح لها بخفض
او زياده وارداتها من الغاز المسال
وموازنه السوق عالميا ولكن بما ان اوروبا
اصبحت معتمده بشكل اكبر بكثير على الغاز
المسال هذا الدور فيه موازنه السوق انتقل
الى الصين من الان فصاعدا فمنذ عام 2020
استطاعت الصين ان ترفع انتاجها المحلي من
الغاز بوا 14% وتزيد من وارداتها من غاز
الانابيب ب 33%
وترفع من مخزونات الغاز لديها بخمسه
وثلاثين في المئه ومن حجم قدرات التسييل
لديها بواقع 19% كل هذه الاوراق في ايدي
الصين تعطيها مرونه عاليه لم تعد اوروبا
تمتلكها في اختيار متى وبكم تشتري من سوق
الغاز المسال اما الاستنتاج الثالث
والاخير فهو انه بات من الواضح ان هناك
حاجه ماسه لمزيد من امدادات الغاز المسال
عالميا بحسب تقديرات شال فان الطلب
العالمي سيرتفع بحلول عام 2040 ليتراوح ما
بين 650 الى 700 مليون طن في السنه الا ان
اكثر سيناريوهات تفاؤلا والتي تحتاج او او
التي تحتسب قطرات تحتاج الحاليه وتلك تحت
الانشاء تضع حجم الامدادات عام 2040 عند
500 مليون طن سنويا فقط
ولكن بالرغم من العجز المتوقع فانه لا
يحفز الكثير من المطورين على الاستثمار
لان حجم الطلب الاوروبي على الغاز المساه
المستقبلا ليس من السهل تقديره فمثلا
استراتيجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي للطاقه
تستهدف خفض الطلب على الغاز بنحو النصف
بحلول عام 20 30 وبالرغم من ان العديد من
المختصين يرون ان تلك المستهدفات تبالغ في
طموحها يبقى السؤال ان لم ينخفض الطلب على
الغاز بالنصف فبكم سينخفض وكيف ستتحرك ما
بعد عام 2030 وهل سينجح الاتحاد الاوروبي
فعلا
بمضاعفه وارداته من الغاز الاثاري الى
المليار متر مكعب سنويا بحلول عام 20 27
كما اعلن سابقا واخرا وليس اخيرا ماذا
سيحدث في حال التوصل الى سلام ما بين
اوروبا وروسيا هل سيعود الغاز الروسي الى
التدفق عبر الانابيب غربا في يوم ما كما
توقع وزير الطاقه القطري مؤخرا كل ذلك
يعني ان سوق الغاز المسال ستواصل التقلبات
الحاده على المدى القصير الى حين اتضاح
تلك الامور
[موسيقى]
نتوقف الان مع فاصل قصير نتابع بعده في
مستقبل الطاقه
تعمل لرفع مبيعاتها المنتجه من مواد معاد
تدويرها بسته اضعاف بحلول عام 20 25
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى مستقبل الطاقه السنه التي
مرت منذ بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه زرعت
الكثير من الشكوك حول مسار تحول الطاقه
وما اذا كانت العناصر متوفره لنجاحه
بالسرعه المطلوبه الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
اكوا باور احدى اكبر الشركات العامله في
مجال الطاقه المتجدده في المنطقه السيد
بادي قدمنتان لديه وجهه نظر مختلفه فهو
يرى ان التحدي امام تحول الطاقه لا يكمن
في توافر المواد الاوليه ولا في التموين
بل في بناء القدرات البشريه لنتابع ما
قاله لمستقبل الطاقه
ولكن في ظل ما يحدث في العالم من ارتفاع
نسب الفائده من القلق من الركود من التضخم
هل ما زالت مستهدفات تحول الطاقه قائمه
عندك
ولكن جميع هذه العوامل المؤثره اذا ما
تحدثنا عن قطاع المعادن فهو بعد الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه شهدت ارتفاعات كبيره
في الاسعار كيف سيؤثر ذلك على قطاع الطاقه
المتجدده
وماذا عن الاستثمارات
[موسيقى]
بورياليس هي شركه النمساويه تعتبر من اكبر
منتجي الباتروكيماويات في اوروبا وتحديدا
البولي اوليفينات الى جانب الاسمده وهي
عباره عن شراكه بين او ام في النمساويه
وشركه ادنوك في ابوظبي وفي مقابله لمستقبل
الطاقم اكد الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
بورياليس توماس غانل ان الشركه تطمح لرفع
مبيعاتها المنتجه من مواد
تدويرها بسته اضعاف بحلول عام 20 25
لنتابع
وهاب سوري
وما هو حجم الخفض في الانبعاثات الذي سيتم
تحقيقه
قطاع البتروكيماويات من اكثر القطاعات
استهلاكا للطاقه وخصوصا للغاز هل هناك اي
خطط لتحويل الاعتماد من الغاز الى الطاقه
المتجدده او الهيدروجين يسويها
وهل التقنيات اليوم لديكم جاهزه لتبني
الهيدروجين او الطاقات المتجدده في حال
جهزيتها لدخول في عمليه تكرير
البتروكيماويات
المقابلتين اجراهما الزميل يحيى الرفاعي
نهايه مستقبل الطاقه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]